- Hey, good afternoon everyone.
Hope everyone's enjoying
their re:Invent 2025
so far this week.
Yeah, thank you so much for coming today.
Before we actually kick things off,
I just want to take a quick show of hands,
how many of you guys have already
built a generative AI
application too, actually helps
some of your users out there trying to
make their lives more effective
or more productive, so far?
A quick show of hands, don't be shy.
It's a good showing actually.
So, and you know, that's
really a testament
of how the amazing the
industry has transformed
the last couple of years.
You know, if you think
about it, so it all started
with like some early
research and development
that actually led to the first
set of in frontier models
that actually showed us,
showed the entire world
the capability or the
possible for letting you help
letting users interface
with a system in their own
natural language and
creatively responding and kind.
And, you know, with
that then it all led to
a whole lot of tools today that, you know,
not only it could actually
go and search for information
for you, it can answer
the question yourself.
It generates new rich
media content based on
a set of descriptions or
captions that you feed it.
It can even generate
brand new code for you
that actually can like
either just prototype
for you on a new concept you want,
you wanna share with people,
or you want to fill a gap
or do some small repair
on your applications.
So that's how quickly the industry evolved
in the last couple years.
But I think for everyone who has said
that they deployed something out there,
they probably also seen
all the challenges involved
and actually getting
that type of application
to a production level quality
that's you feel comfortable
giving to your users over time.
So, with that, my name is Gene Ting,
I'm a principal solutions
architect at Amazon Web Services.
And joining me today is Austin Bell
and Shaurya Kethireddy from Slack,
as we gonna talk about their
journey on overcoming some
of those challenges so
that they can actually
delight millions of Slack
users around the world
with Amazon Bedrock and Nova.
So, to start things off making
a generative AI application
production worthy follow
some similar steps
as what you would've
thought about in the past
for more traditional
applications on the high level.
You're gonna have to think hard about
who you're building towards,
the types of personas they are,
which defines the user requirements
and the functions that you're
gonna be thinking about
to design your application.
Once those decisions are made,
you're gonna have to
think about reliability,
operational excellence, cost management,
especially as your
application grows over time.
You always wanna make
sure that you can protect
the application, protect 'em
from harmful damage to it,
protecting your user session, their data.
But what's kind of new
and an interesting nuance
that comes with generative
AI applications as well,
how to make sure that your system
can actually respond to
your users in a safe manner
and how to make sure
that it's only handling
the types of workflows
and types of requests
that you design the system for.
So some key factors to think about when
you defining your user requirements
and designing your
generative AI application
includes a couple of facets here.
Sometimes you're gonna have to think about
whether or not you're
going to build functions
through static LLM workflows.
Sometimes you're going want to see
how you could apply more
dynamic agenetic workflows.
Well, but the common thing about these
is that they all involve
different levels of complexity
based on the tasks that
you're asking to accomplish.
Sometimes you wanna
respond instantaneously
or as quick as possible in real time,
such as answering a search
phrase and giving back
a rich summarization of search results.
Sometimes you wanna take a whole lot of
conversational thread and text
and summarize that on a daily basis.
Those are more latency insensitive types
of workflows over there.
But the main thing is also it's like,
just like traditional applications,
you always have to be cognizant
and aware around latency sensitivity
for your users based
on the type of use case
that's being considered at the time.
This is where Amazon Bedrock comes in
where we talked about different complexity
for different tasks, you
have a lot of selections
and models within Amazon
Bedrock to choose from
to actually able to
accomplish those tasks.
Making those choices helps
you having that select option
and making those choices helps
you see which ones are best
for the type of use case
you're trying to accomplish.
And also helps with managing
costs over time, as well.
And similarly with
figuring out is real time
or asynchronous response,
you have also choices
with Bedrock.
You could choose what provision,
throughput, priority tiers
or just the standard tier
to answer most questions.
You could defer some inference
to either batch inference
or to the flex tier if you wanted,
if you're not in such a
rush to actually respond
to those questions.
And making those choices also
helps with managing costs.
As your application matures
and improves over time,
you want have a strategy
on how you're gonna upgrade
and replace those models.
Either upgrade to a new
version of that same model,
upgrade to a different model that you see
that it could also
accomplish the same task.
You also have to have a way
to optimize model responses
over and over iteratively over time.
This is where Bedrock prompt management
and prompt tuning comes into play.
You could have, you
could use LN as a judge
and also have a a set of
prompts that you catalog
so you could actually apply
them to different models
to compare over time.
You could use prompt tuning
and use the Prompt Optimizer
to get suggestions on how you, you could
basically submit different
prompts and context
and see what the results are.
So after all those fundamental
application decisions
are made, you wanna think
about how you're gonna operate
and basically run at scale.
So starting with a choice
around which region
you're gonna pick to actually
host your application,
based on your user requirements
or regulatory needs,
that's gonna define
where you're gonna start
your interactions with Bedrock.
You wanna establish a monitoring strategy
immediately from there.
You'll be either monitoring for time
to first token for your for your request.
You may be using CloudWatch metrics
to actually view end
to end-to-end latency.
How often are you getting errors,
how often you're throttling.
You wanna use CloudWatch logs for example,
or your own login system to actually see
how the agents are
responding or what the LM
is doing on the backend.
You wanna able tune for performance.
So you wanna have you tune
performance always comes
into play some sort of caching strategy.
You could use explicit prompt
caching for example on Bedrock
to actually able to cache common
and frequently frequent used inputs
so that you could save time
and costs on transforming
that input into to input tokens.
And we talked about how
Bedrock had model flexibility
to help with cost management.
It also very much comes
into play to help you
with resiliency as well.
So that if for ever reason, yeah the model
starts misbehaving or you have
some availability concerns
around that, around that model,
you should always establish
a deeper model strategy
to able have your application covered.
As your application really
grows out over time,
you wanna be able to use other
regions that has capacity
that's also helps in those models.
With Bedrock cross region
inference, you could ask it
to actually send your
request to another region
that's hosting that model
what is on the same continent
or even halfway across the world, as well.
Secured by design is
always an essential part
of productionizing your application.
Starting with that basic
blueprint we talked about before,
the first thing you
could rest assure is that
Bedrock has been designed
so that model providers
cannot access environment
that's actually hosting
their model.
And on the flip side as well,
we don't by design share
any of the inputs and
outputs that's being fed in
and coming out from the models
that you use on Bedrock as well.
You can imply IAM policies to make sure
that only the specific
parts and specific users
in your organization and
you and in your environment
can actually access the models
that you have already started
leveraging on Bedrock.
You can use service control
policies to make sure
that only the specific models
that your organization has approved
is actually available
within your infrastructure.
You even have the added
control with VPC endpoints
so that reaching Amazon Bedrock
through your infrastructure
has to go through a specific path.
And remember how we talked
about using cross region
inference to able to reach capacity
wherever is available on Bedrock?
Based on your specific
regulatory requirements
or data sovereignty needs,
you can even restrict
that cross region inference behavior
to only certain geographic locations
of your choosing as well.
So coming back to this nuance that we have
around making sure your
application responds
in a safe manner and only handling things
that you have specifically designed for.
Let's talk about coming from
the basic response workflow.
Looking at the user input side of things,
you can apply Amazon Bedrock
guardrails to make sure
that you could filter out
for a certain keyword.
You could basically
deny dangerous content.
You could actually pick
other types of custom topics
that you don't want the system to handle.
And if any of those
policies are triggered,
you can have Bedrock respond back over
custom moderator response.
On the other end of the spectrum
after your initial inputs have been vetted
and then fed into the model,
you can have Bedrock guardrails again,
apply those tapes, same types of policies
and add the additional
automated reasoning checks
for correctness before sending
the response back to the user.
So now that we talked
about a basic blueprint on
how to go from ideation to production,
let's see how one of our
biggest customers, Slack,
apply some of these
principles and rigor so
that they can actually
deliver Slack AI effectively,
securely and efficiently.
All right, so take it away Austin.
- Great, thank you for
that introduction Gene
and thank you all for coming.
We are gonna spend this time talking about
how we at Slack are able
deliver our Slack AI features
effectively, securely and efficiently.
Specifically, our goal here is to be able
to enable generative AI to permeate
throughout the Slack product.
And it's very easy to
sort of get to that 80%
of a generative AI feature,
but really sets that moat
and sets you apart.
Is that extra 20% of
becoming more cost efficient,
high or having higher quality?
We're gonna spend this presentation going
through our journey of
how we were able to sort
of meet our scale and meet our
quality needs here at Slack.
Specifically, we're gonna talk
about three different areas.
We're gonna discuss how we developed
our infrastructure layer that allowed us
to sort of meet our scaling needs in a way
that was highly secure and met all
of our compliance requirements.
We're gonna talk about how we developed
an internal experimentation
framework that allowed us
to objectively measure the quality
of our generative AI outputs
and give us the confidence
that we are actually
tangibly moving the needle
in that quality.
Lastly, we're gonna talk about how those
two different sections come
together to actually enable us
to integrate generative
AI more seamlessly across
the product.
But first, a little bit about who we are.
My name is Austin Bell.
I am a director here at Slack,
responsible across machine
learning search and AI
and I'm joined by my colleague.
- Hey everyone, my name is Shaurya.
I'm an engineer here at Slack working on
our infrastructure and platform team.
- So just to level set a little bit,
I'm gonna assume some
familiarity of what Slack is,
but for anybody who's not
aware of our Slack AI offering,
we support over a dozen
different generative AI features
and tools that kind of spanned
the spectrum of complexity
and use cases.
For example, we offer the ability
to do AI summaries across a variety
of different product surface areas.
We have our in-house QA systems
where you can ask questions
and find information related
to the data that you house
within Slack, we have the
ability to create daily digest
to get up to date very quickly on
everything that's going on.
These are just a small number of examples
and we continue to add more
on a very, very regular basis.
Now for our first topic,
I'm gonna pass it over
to my colleague Sharia,
who's gonna discuss
how we have built our
infrastructure layer here at Slack.
- Thank you Austin for the introduction.
Hey everyone, I'm here to talk
about how we scale Slack AI
to the millions of daily
active users that we have.
So generally when we
talk about generative AI,
it usually is around speed.
How fast are tokens coming,
how fast is a product moving
and how fast is the
market moving, as well.
But here at Slack we
also add factor of trust.
We ensure that the services
that we use have the trust
that we need to protect
the customer's data
and their trust in us to ensure that
they're able to work within our platform.
So one quote that we usually
go by is the real test
of scalable infrastructure
isn't just how fast it grows,
but it's also how well it
protects what matters as it grows.
So as you can imagine,
a lot of people have
all their working content within Slack.
We want to ensure that whichever
features that we do add,
it enables them to keep working with Slack
while not having to add
any roadblocks in there.
So before going into the technical aspect
of how we are scaling Slack AI is,
I like to set a little
bit of context about
what product promises that
we have for our features.
The first pillar is trust.
So whenever we started
scaling out Slack AI question
that we've gotten a lot from customers is,
is our data being used to
train generative AI models?
And the answer is no.
So we don't train generative
models on customer data,
we don't log customer data.
We also allow the admins
of the Slack workspaces
to opt out of features.
So this means that the admins
can opt into a certain feature
or opt out a certain feature as well.
We also have zero retention of the data
and the data that's being
sent to the LM providers
is not being shared.
So as Gene mentioned,
the inputs and outputs
are not being shared.
The second pillar is security.
We operate in a FedRAMP
moderate compliance space.
So we ensure that the
services that we use meet
that rigorous standard set
by the federal guidelines.
We also make sure that the services
that we do use stay
within our trust boundary
as there's a lot of
data being moved around
and we also have
technical access controls.
So this means that for example,
if there's message in a private channel,
we don't want people who are not in
that channel to have access to it.
So we ensure that there's
security of the messages
and even the answers being shared.
The third pillar I'd like
to cover is reliability.
So having trust and
security is not enough.
We also need to have the
features set be highly available.
This is what enables the customers
to actually use it in their daily process.
On top of that, we also want
to have contextual relevance.
So this means that whenever a
customer is sending a request,
we want to make sure that the answer
that they're getting is actually relevant
to what they're asking for
and transparency as well.
So this means that whenever
they do get an answer,
we're able to add
citations wherever possible
so the customers can backtrack
to see the main message
that the LLM may have used
to generate that particular.
So having all these pillars,
it may be pretty easy
to do it when we have 10 users,
but let's take a look at how
Slack is operating right now.
Every week we are processing more than
one to 5 billion messages, a
hundred to 500 million files
and one to 5 billion searches.
So as you can see, many
of like Slack is operating
at a massive scale.
We can't just plug in our AI
features into a public API
and hope for the best.
We need to ensure that the services
that we use are properly
tested behind the scenes
and can handle our millions
and billions of requests
without breaking a sweat.
As well, as ensuring our
security and trust postures.
So now that we've set the
context of the products
and also the scale of Slack,
let's start with the past
journey of how we used
to serve Slack AI in mid
2023 up until mid 2024,
at the time we had limited LLM options,
we had high costs, low flexibility,
and we're running in a provision
throughput environment.
From there we have now gone to the future
where we have high flexibility,
high utilization efficiency,
and as well as increased reliability.
So when we first started in mid 2023,
we were looking for services
that Amazon offered,
which were within the FedRAMP
moderate compliance space
as well as compliant with our
security and trust postures.
So we started with SageMaker
and for context too,
Slack mostly operates within
the US East one region
and we have our VPC which
contains the Slack instance.
From there, the requests go
through the VPC endpoint,
like the Slack AI requests,
which is basically
allowing the requests to
go through the internal
networking of AWS.
And that request goes to
the SageMaker endpoint,
which is the basically like
the wrapper around the model.
And when we first started
we only had one model
and this model was served in
a provision throughput manner.
And you may also see
a small box in our VPC
called the concurrency checker.
And this is what we use to maintain load.
So at times of peak load we were able
to shed the lower priority requests.
So for example, we have
three priority internally,
the highest priority, which
is the most latency sensitive,
the medium priority,
which can be done within
a five to 10 minute SLA.
And then our third tier priority,
which is like our batch
jobs, which are on overnight.
And during the times of high concurrency
when we have our cluster
pretty much at peak utilization
instead of having to scale
up, which could take more than
an hour at that time we
were able to load shed
pretty quickly.
Though this worked during
the initial days of Slack AI,
when we were still scaling up, we noticed
that Slack AI was also getting added on
pretty exponential exponentially
to the customer basis.
So we noticed a couple of problems.
The first one was peaky traffic.
We had two different types
of requests coming in,
the time sensitive ones
and the batch workloads.
So these are pretty predictable
in our day-to-day scenarios.
But these had different
consistencies of throughput
and also it was difficult to obtain GPUs
at the time it was the GPU crunch.
So it was taking us weeks to get the GPUs
that we need to scale up
for our new customer bases
who are added to Slack AI.
And because of the GPU
crunch, we weren't able
to scale up and down easily.
We were having to
maintain our GPU instances
in our on demand capacity reserve.
So then we were able to hold onto those
during the non-peak times.
So the impact of these two problems
were that we were over-provisioned
for the majority of the day and this was
because of having to keep
our GPUs up and running.
And because of this we had
our infrastructure scaled
to support the peak traffic,
which isn't ideal as this cost,
this basically causes cost inefficiency.
We're paying for instances and GPU time,
which we aren't actively using
to serve customer requests.
And because of this
fixed cost that we have,
we weren't able to diversify our LLMs.
We only had one or maybe even two.
But this also slowed us
down when experimenting
with new models or even
adding new features.
So keeping these problems in mind,
we had a vision about
where we wanted to go.
We wanted to look for a new
service which is managed
but also gives us a diversity of models.
So this is when we were
able to come across Bedrock.
So in mid 2024, Bedrock became
FedRAMP moderate compliant
and we were able to take a more serious
look into the service.
We were able to serve all these requests
within our trust boundary.
And Bedrock also promises
that the input outputs
don't get shared with the providers
so that they're not able to
train on our inputs and outputs.
Bedrock also has a whole
collection of frontier models.
So this was able, this was
enabling our product engineers
to add more features.
And with Bedrock two we were able
to see models getting
added to the model registry
at a faster rate.
So within a day of whenever
these models get published,
they're within the Bedrock platform.
Once we essentially set Bedrock
as our service to migrate to
we a couple of migration steps to ensure
that we have a very reliable
migration while keeping
customer trust and no downtime.
The first aspect was to
understand Bedrock infrastructure
and the two differences were the provision
throughput and the on demand.
And because in the SageMaker
world we were in the provision
throughput infrastructure type,
we decided to keep the same in Bedrock
to make the migration
easier and then handle
the on demand transition the next stage.
The second part was to do
some internal load testing
and doing some compute calculation.
So this means that we're working
on scientifically figuring
out what is the equivalent
of Bedrock Mall units
to SageMaker compute that we already had.
So then we were able to
get the equivalent compute
without having to guess and check.
So here's an example of
one of our load tests.
We were able to run Claude Instant
and Claude Haiku on both
SageMaker and Bedrock.
And as you can see, for Claude Instant,
it's like a one-to-one mapping.
So when we did run SageMaker on a P4D,
it was equivalent to a Bedrock Mall unit.
And when we ran a Claude Haiku instance
on a P5 instance type, it was two P5's
were equivalent to one Bedrock Mall unit.
So by using these ratios we were able
to get the equivalent
compute and we worked with
the Amazon Bedrock service
team to get that delivered
to our account.
Once we got the compute delivered to us,
we were able to start
running shadow traffic.
So this means that whenever a
request was sent to SageMaker,
we were sending a duplicate
request to Bedrock.
So then we were able
to get an understanding
of the internals of the service,
and this also helped us
out while building out
our monitoring dashboards as well.
So we were able to verify the latencies,
the time of first token
and the other metrics
that we had in place.
Once the shadow traffic was
running a 100% for two weeks,
we started to do a full cutover process.
So this was in branches
too, so we started with
a 1%, 5%, 10% and 100%.
And this essentially means that
instead of the shadow mode,
now we're serving the
response that was sent
by the Bedrock service instead
of the SageMaker service.
So by going to Bedrock,
this helped us save money
and we were also able to experiment more,
but we noticed a couple
more gaps that we could
kind of work towards to make
this service more efficient.
The first one was we weren't
able to scale PT still,
it was still a static compute cluster
and because of this we
were still experiencing
some cost inefficiencies.
And then within the platform
on our side, we noticed
that it would be more
helpful if we're able
to add backup models.
So during the times when
Bedrock models had regressions
or we were noticing some
features not performing
as expected, we were able to
add backup models for them
so that we can essentially reroute them
without having to do any code
changes during incidents.
We also added features for emergency stops
for the particular
features and the models.
So this is like basically it goes in play
with the backup models.
Whenever emergency stop is turned on,
a whole feature can be
potentially turned off.
And if a model is turned off on our side,
then all the requests are
rerouted to our backup models.
And when using Amazon
Bedrock two, we were exposed
to being able to use different
tools that models have.
So for example, tools,
prompt caching, guardrails,
and other features that
the models do have.
And we were able to expand
our internal AI platform
to enable our developers
to have access to these.
So from going from provision throughput,
we noticed that we
weren't able to scale PT.
So this was when we
decided to move towards
the on-demand world.
And this is a different
infrastructure type
as it's now based more
on quotas rather than
the Bayer instances.
And this is being done
on a tokens per minute,
the input tokens per minute
and request per minute basis.
We also had a lot of metadata on our side
during the provision throughput era.
So we were able to
essentially calculate the RPM
and TPMS from our metadata
and pass that compute request
to Amazon Bedrock to get those quotas
delivered to our accounts.
So similar to how it was
within the SageMaker world,
we had our Slack app within
the US East one region,
the VPC holds a Slack instances,
the request goes to the VPC endpoint,
which does all the internal routing goes
through the Bedrock service.
And then based on the model
ID that we add to the request,
it will point it to that particular model.
One difference here from the
SageMaker architecture diagram
is instead of a concurrency checker,
we had a RPM and TPM checker on our side
and the RPM TPM is for
the requests per minute
and tokens per minute.
And this enabled us to
essentially like keep our
different features under control.
And this means like we're able
to isolate certain features
from taking over our
entire Bedrock cluster.
And a different benefit that
we also got from Bedrock
on Demand is now we're able to use
US cross region inference profiles.
And because we are a
FedRAMP moderate shop,
we needed to keep it
within the US boundaries
and Bedrock provides that ability
and by going to US West two as well,
we're able to get our
compute delivered to us
at a much faster rate as we
had two regions to choose from.
So with all of this,
we had a bunch of wins
at the end of the migration.
When we first started, we had one LLM
to start to choose from.
And by the end of the migration
and current state right
now we're experimenting
and serving greater than
15 LLMs in production.
We also have increased reliability.
So because of the higher
flexibility of LLMs,
we were able to fall
back to certain models,
we were able to quickly switch
models during incident times
and even experiment around
to see what is the best model
to serve for quality and cost.
On top of that, our biggest number win
was the utilization efficiency.
During the whole migration,
we were still experiencing
an exponential scale
increase of Slack AI usage
as customers were still onboarding,
but even with that
increased customer base,
we saw greater than 90%
savings and in dollar values,
this was greater than 20 million, as well.
So to close it off, we started
off with a quote saying
that it's not about how fast
you can scale infrastructure,
but it's about how you
can secure your data
as well as scaling it.
And by using the services that Amazon has,
we were able to deliver all
of our AI features at scale
by collaborating with our internal cloud
and platform teams as
well as collaborating
with the AWS side, as well.
Thank you, and now I'll pass it to Austin,
talk about how we were able
to serve it with high quality.
(audience claps)
- Thank you for that Shaurya.
We're gonna switch gears here a little bit
and we're gonna talk
about how we've developed
kind of an internal experimentation
framework that allows us
to more objectively measure the quality
of our generative AI outputs
so we can actually start
to move the needle on this quality.
Now this is a quote from
an engineer at Slack,
and I don't know if you've
ever been in this situation,
but you demo a generative AI feature.
You get it really nice looking
and you're really excited it comes down to
time to productionize it.
But you just have to kind of, you know,
refine a couple edge
cases in terms of quality.
You make prompt changes,
you make pipeline changes
and you actually start to get that out.
But after a few days you start
to notice you actually
regressed in certain areas.
This turns into kind of a cycle
and a bit of a whack-a-mole situation
where you're trying to fix one issue,
but leading to another issue with actually
no quality improvements
over the course of weeks.
So why is this the case?
Well, evaluating generative
outputs, it's difficult.
We are kind of, or have been
in a bit of a paradigm shift
from classical machine learning
where in online settings
you could leverage
engagement metrics to evaluate quality
or in offline settings
you could leverage things
like precision or recall.
The outputs of generative
AI are significantly
more subjective.
What I consider a good
output may be very different
than what you consider a good output.
It may also be dependent
on the product surface area
that you actually want to display
this generative AI output.
So the question becomes
how do you actually start
to measure this in a way
that meets your goals
and actually continues
to allow you to improve.
Now a key thing that we
believe here at Slack
is that you can really only improve
what you actually have
the ability to measure.
So we first went on a journey
of actually trying to define
what we wanted to measure.
We defined by two pillars, quality.
This is what we kind of refer to as like,
is the answer giving you
what you actually wanted?
Is it accurate to safety?
Are we fostering the correct environment
that we want at Slack?
Are we ensuring that your data's as secure
as it possibly can be?
Within each of these, we
further broke these down.
On the quality side, we
broke it down into two
separate categories.
First objective measurements.
This is what we consider kind of more
of our deterministic outputs.
Things that are somewhat table stakes,
being able to render it properly,
being able to parse a JSON
output or an XML output.
Are we formatting IDs correctly?
Are we formatting links correctly
so you can navigate Slack properly?
Things that if we don't
have the user's gonna notice
and it doesn't actually matter the content
of your generative AI because
they're not gonna be able
to look past some of these issues.
On the harder side, we have
the subjective measurements.
These are things like factual accuracy.
Are you in fact telling
the truth based off
of your grounded context?
Answer relevancy.
Are you answering the question
that the user actually asked?
Attribution accuracy, this is
a big problem for us at Slack.
Are we attributing the correct content
to the correct user or
to the correct file?
On the safety side, we
also broke this down
into two separate categories.
Harm and security.
Harm refers to what we do
around measure around toxicity.
Are we capturing bias?
Are we ensuring that it
is a good environment
and that our LLM is responding
in the way that aligns
with our values?
Second security.
Are we protecting against
prompt injection attacks
to the extent that we can?
Are we preventing even search poisoning
that you don't want to
do that is unintended
or even is intended at search poisoning.
Now that's kind of step one,
defining what you
actually want to measure.
The next part is actually
generating the evaluators
that will give you the ability
to actually measure this.
Now this has been sort of a journey.
Starting at the beginning we
wanted to do a few things.
We wanted to ensure that
our product engineers
had the ability to very
quickly manually review
the outputs across small data sets
based off of their prompt changes
or their pipeline changes.
We also wanted to introduce a variety
of automated programmatic
metrics that allowed us
to capture in an automated fashion
these objective measurements
within the quality pillar.
Things that allow us to ensure
that we're not regressing on formatting
or rendering capabilities that we consider
at table stakes here at Slack.
We increasing complexity in this journey,
and this is kind of where
we are today here at Slack.
We start to tackle some of
those more complex definitions
of quality.
We leverage LLM based quality metrics
to be able to measure factual accuracy
or to be able to measure answer relevancy.
We leverage guardrails to
capture safety and harm issues.
The overall goal here is that by combining
these automated programmatic
metrics alongside LLM judges
and guardrails, we can start
to evaluate the quality
of our generative AI on
much larger data sets
that are much more
representative of production.
This gives us the ability
to run much larger
scale experiments and tests.
Now where do we go from here?
Well, the goal is to
essentially start to develop
kind of CICD for the generative
AI, giving us the ability
to define verified outputs
where we can automate
a series of tests so we
can capture regressions
and lead to quality
improvements in a much quicker
and more efficient way.
Let me take a step back here
and talk a little bit about
some of the things that I just mentioned.
At Slack we run dozens of different task
specific LLM judges.
We work with each product team
that develops product AI
features here at Slack
to come up with a rubric on
what actually is the definition
of quality for their particular feature.
This changes for every single feature.
So given the ability to our engineers
to only define kind of a
rubric without actually
having to write any code
to deploy these allows us
to get these out very quickly.
We also leverage Amazon
Bedrock guardrails,
which gives us the ability
to measure toxicity,
harm prompt injection
in a very, very easy way
on both inputs and outputs of our LLMs.
So we've kind of
highlighted two steps here.
We first defined what we wanted to measure
and then we defined how we measured it.
But what really allows our engineers
to be productive is kind
of developing the workflow
that allows 'em to
utilize these capabilities
in their day-to-day
development experience.
We kind of, if you have a
machine learning background,
this may seem somewhat familiar to you.
We first do a series of
offline experimentation.
We start on what we call
kind of golden sets.
These are verified outputs
from our internal data
that allow users to kind
of make prompt changes
to their LLMs and perform manual review
on just like small data
sets of like 10 to 20.
If they feel confident with that,
they can move to running their experiments
on what we call validation sets.
These are much larger in size
and are much more representative
of our production data.
This way using the
combination of these automated
programmatic metrics as well
as these quality metrics,
they can look to capture
large scale regressions
as well as ensure that
they're actually making
the quality improvement
that they intended to.
Now a key thing here is
that at each step we want
to provide the fastest
feedback loop possible.
This gives our engineers
the ability to fail
as quickly as possible, go
back to the drawing board
and ship features more quickly.
Now, while our goal here
is to ultimately make this
as automated as possible,
leveraging human in the loop
is key to this.
We aren't perfect in a
lot of our development
of these evaluators.
So giving our engineers the ability
to actually see the
impact of their changes
in the LLM response
very quickly across data
will allow them to move
significantly faster.
Now, after you've sort of validated
a lot of this in your offline setting,
we move into online evaluation.
This is where we start to run AB tests
and we integrate all of those evaluators
that I've mentioned into
our AB tests as well
so that you can actually
measure both across
these quality metrics as
well as user feedback metrics
before you actually make the decision
to roll out to production.
Now, the key thing here
is that you actually have
the confidence that you are
making the quality change.
You are not regressing in certain areas
before too many of your
users actually see it.
Stepping back, I'm gonna
talk about a few things
that I just mentioned as part of that,
we have three different types of data sets
that we typically operate
within golden sets,
which have been sort of manually vetted.
These are very small 10 to 50 samples
and give our engineers the ability
to manually review the outputs,
validation sets ranging typically
between a hundred and a thousand samples.
This is where those automated quality
and programmatic metrics
really start to shine,
as you can imagine, reviewing
say a thousand samples
as kind of impossible for a human.
Then the AB testing where we
typically run these experiments
on somewhere between one
to 25% of Slack AI queries
for that particular feature.
So that's all nice, but is it worth it?
I've just kind of picked
three examples here
that kind of showcase some
of the different areas
that we look to tackle here at Slack.
On the prompt engineering
side, we recently changed
how we serialize the content that we send
to the LLM resulting in
a 5 and 6% improvement
in both factual and user
attribution accuracy respectively.
We oftentimes run model
upgrades when a new version
of a model or a new LLM comes out.
A recent upgrade resulted in 11% increase
in user satisfaction as
well as a 3 to 5% increase
in key quality metrics.
Now we run that flow in a
much more automated fashion
for every single LLM upgrade that we do
because we've actually seen a
new version lead to regression
and decided to not roll it out.
Outside of quality, cost
management is a key area for us.
Sometimes you want to
just maintain quality
while reducing costs or improving latency.
A recent change allowed us
to move a similar quality LLM
or change resulting in
a 60% cost reduction.
So we've talked about-
- [Audience Member] Can
you talk more about that?
- I will, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We've talked about two different things,
independently, our how we
built the infrastructure layer,
which gave us the ability
to utilize our LMS
much more efficiently,
choose between different LLMs
and give us the ability
to switch seamlessly.
We then talked about how we developed kind
of this internal experimentation
framework that allows us
to actually measure the
quality of our AI outputs
and have confidence that the changes
we want to make are the
changes we are making.
In this section, I'm gonna
go through how we utilize
both of those to more seamlessly
integrate generative AI
across the application in a way
that is cost efficient while
maintaining the quality
and scale that our users expect.
To do that I'm gonna walk
through a couple a use case,
but before that I just wanna
highlight there's a a spectrum
of generative AI complexity.
On the low complexity
side, you have things
that maybe in the past were done
by traditional machine learning
models, classification,
converting unstructured to
structured data, parsing data.
You jump to the medium complexity
where it's summarization,
very basic image generation,
content editing capabilities.
Then on the high complexity side,
a little bit more of what the
media likes to talk about.
Agenetic workflows, video
generation, tool use,
these bigger things.
Now here at Slack we have a large number
of generative AI applications
and they all span this spectrum
ranging from low complexity
all the way to high complexity.
You don't want to use your
state-of-the-art frontier LLM
for every single use case,
but it's a tough question
to answer like what is the exact right LLM
to be able to utilize
that will meet your goals
without sacrificing quality to your users.
So we're gonna step
through a specific use case
tackling this low complexity
area that we refer to
as search query
understanding here at Slack.
But first I'm gonna
revisit the scale slide
that Shaurya has shown
highlighting the search area.
Now we run a lot of
searches here at Slack.
While the bulk of those may
just be finding a person,
finding a channel, a fraction of those
are highly complex searches
where you want to ask questions
to your data or run searches
across a large number
of messages.
So even a fraction of this
number can result in high cost
if you are not running efficiently.
So what is search query understanding?
So let's say a user comes into Slack
and adds the following search term.
"Can you find me the FY25 sales deck
that John Doe sent me recently?"
Now we may not want to send that
to our search cluster directly,
it might not be helpful,
but there's a lot of
information hidden in there
that allows us to more target our searches
and improve the chances
that we're actually finding
the files or the messages that
you are actually looking for.
So we run it through kind of a
large language model pipeline
that allows us to generate
JSON, that includes filters
and other information that
you might be relevant to you.
Let's break this down.
We can see that the actual
query you might wanna search
isn't that full thing.
Maybe it's just FY25
sales PowerPoint deck.
Now this is just one query, but oftentimes
you run multiple queries in parallel.
So there might be multiple
versions of this search term.
You use the term recently.
So this gives us the indication
that we might be able
to condense this to a specific time range
in the past three months
to increase the chances
of finding what we're looking for.
You said that you're
looking for a sales deck,
now that likely includes a type of a file
called a presentation.
So can we limit to only threads
or conversations that
include presentations?
You also mentioned that it was
John Doe that sent it to you,
so let's only look at conversations
or threads that included him.
So what does this actually look
like in our search pipeline
user sends of search, we
have machine learning models
that allow us to quickly
and very quickly determine
is this an informational search
or is this a navigational search?
If it's a navigational search,
you go through a very specific search
and machine learning ranking pipeline.
If it's an informational search,
we then go through our
query understanding pipeline
to try to better target your actual search
before then going to the
rest of our search retrieval
machine learning and then
eventually LLM response.
So where did we start here?
So we had a problem our
existing LLM that we were using
for this case, it worked,
it met our quality goals,
but it exceeded our search latency budget
and it was extremely
high cost given the scale
that we needed to operate at.
So what we wanted to do in
this particular use case
is we wanted to switch or
leverage prompt engineering
that allowed us to maintain
quality while simultaneously
reducing latency as well as our costs.
Now the benefit is that we had both
of these infrastructure layer changes
as well as this experimentation framework.
So we wanted to see how we
could utilize both of these
to ensure that we could
select the right LLM
for this particular problem,
while simultaneously,
having the confidence that we are meeting
all three of those goals.
So I'm gonna walk you through
how this actually looks
in our internal experimentation framework.
This is just a small summary
of what it might look like
when we run an offline experiment.
We compare the LLM in this case Nova-lite
to the original LLM that we were using
to determine if this is actually
leading to the improvements
that we want it to be.
Most specifically, we
were looking at latency
as well as key quality metrics.
This is a rolled up summary.
We actually have dozens
of different evaluators
that then aggregate up
into these summaries.
Now this is run on just a
very, very small sample set,
but as you can see, we saw
significant reductions in latency
as well as improvements in
quality on this small sample.
Now with these kind of like offline tests,
we felt confident that
we were actually making
the improvements that we wanted to.
So we moved to an online evaluation.
We started to run an AB test,
and this is just a couple
of photos from that
tackling the key metrics
that we were concerned about.
Specifically we wanted to look at latency
as well as quality metrics in terms of our
automated quality metrics as
well as user satisfaction.
What we saw is that we
significantly improved latency
and we had no significant
change across both
user satisfaction as well as
our automated quality metrics.
So what did this mean?
Well, for query understanding,
we ultimately switched
to Nova-lite and the result
was that we were able to do so
after a series of prompt changes with
no user visible regression in quality,
while simultaneously
reducing P50 latency by 46%
and reducing our cost to serve
for this particular feature by 70%.
So what have we unlocked here?
We had these two independent sections,
these infrastructure improvements,
which gave us the ability
to select the right LLM for the feature,
to be able to run our
infrastructure at a much more
efficient utilization.
We also had our quality
and evaluation system,
which gave us the ability to perform
more objective benchmarking and evaluation
of the quality of our
generative AI outputs.
And so with this, we are
able to select the right LLM
for the job, maximize the
time we actually spend
prompt engineering while
minimizing engineering time
that goes into this,
run our infrastructure
much more efficiently and
actually have the confidence
that when we communicate
to the improvements
that we are making to
other teams, to leadership,
that those improvements are actual.
And so we do this across dozens and dozens
of different features.
What has been the result
of all of these changes?
In the past year, we've
seen a 90% reduction
in the cost to serve Slack
AI by monthly active user,
simultaneously, we've increased
the scale that we operate at
by nearly 5X.
We did this all while
increasing user satisfaction
and user feedback by
ranging from 15 to 30%
across Slack AI's marquee features.
Great.
Thank you all for taking
the time to watch us today.
Happy to answer any questions.